with every passing year it seems like
more and more physical retailers fall
off the map as they struggle to keep up
with the online revolution
retailers as big as jc penney j crew
neiman marcus tier one imports toys r us
price electronics and even sears have
all filed for bankruptcy or shut down it
completely
and with the surge of the pandemic it
seems like this trend would only
accelerate and that's exactly what
happened throughout 2020 as dyn
retailers completely collapsed
but as these weak retailers left the
space the surviving retailers have
emerged stronger than ever before
in fact according to the us government
in 2021 retail sales grew by 18 while
online sales only grew by 14
now you could chalk this up to a rebound
from pandemic lows and i'm sure that
plays a role
but this confirms that there are certain
products that people prefer to buy in
person even if they're available online
otherwise why would consumers have gone
back to physical retailers
also given that a bunch of physical
retailers shut down it during the
pandemic you would think that it would
be harder for the remaining retailers to
make a comeback but that doesn't seem to
be the case
in fact the national retail federation
predicts that 72 percent of u.s sales
will still occur in brick and mortar
stores in 2024.
so why are physical retailers making a
comeback and is this sustainable or just
a fluke
one of the biggest strengths of physical
retailers is the delivery and return
process
while amazon has continuously pushed on
delivery times from weeks to days to
hours there's often still quite a bit of
friction within these processes
first of all you have the package missed
delivery problem
i'm sure all of us have received one of
our neighbor's packages or our packages
have ended up at our neighbor's house
and sometimes you don't even know where
your package went and it's just gone
forever whenever this happens you have
to file a complaint with the retailer
and ups or fedex and it's just a massive
headache
in fact i bet a lot of consumers don't
even file lost package complaints
especially for cheap products just to
avoid the hassle
while this is simply a minor annoyance
for cheap products where this becomes a
serious problem is expensive products
i don't think any of us want to deal
with a new smartphone or laptop being
delivered to some random dude in the
city
now of course there is the option of
requesting a signed delivery for
expensive products but this isn't
necessarily all that convenient you now
have to spend your entire day at home
waiting for the delivery guy there's
also the problem of porch pirates which
is especially a problem within big
cities
in fact over 10 percent of all packages
disappear without an explanation in the
major u.s cities
and given that most of us make at least
one online purchase every month we're
talking about dealing with at least one
lost package every year and then there's
the problem of returns returning
products has always been one of the
biggest hassles of the online shopping
experience
26 percent of online shoppers say that
they never return an online order and 65
say that they rarely return an online
order
this is quite ironic when you consider
that online return rates are still way
higher than brick and mortar return
rates
on average shoppers return five to ten
percent of in-store purchases while
shoppers return 15 to 40 percent of
online purchases
this means that if most consumers
weren't too lazy to return online orders
this number would be even higher
meanwhile the successful physical
retailers have figured out how to
perfectly combine the online and
physical shopping experiences to offer
the best of both worlds
for example with most stores you can do
curbside pickup
this is perfect if you want to order
something online but don't want to deal
with the delivery with the curbside you
don't even have to get out of your car
but you can easily ensure that your
package doesn't go to someone else and
that it's the right product
also it's not really a hassle to pick up
the product either if you plan it right
you can just pick up your purchase when
you come back from work similarly if you
don't want the product you can simply
drop it off and store the next day after
work
considering this i believe a lot of
americans will prefer curbside pickup
even over home delivery
and as the convenience disparity between
physical and online shopping shrinks
physical retailers will simply continue
to make up ground
aside from physical retailers shining in
the delivery and return categories
physical retailers will continue to kill
it when it comes to on-demand products
like groceries
while there are services like instacart
and whole foods home delivery there's no
doubt that these options are still
extremely expensive
and most americans are unwilling to pay
such high delivery fees to simply
receive everyday goods like groceries
this isn't anything new but it wasn't
until recently that physical retailers
have started to leverage this advantage
specifically with curbside grocery
delivery
this isn't as advantageous for retailers
that only sell groceries but this is
extremely helpful for mega retailers
like walmart target sam's club and
costco who sell everything under the sun
let's say you need a new mouse instead
of ordering it from amazon why not
bundle it with a walmart grocery order
that you're gonna pick up later that
afternoon
not only would you receive the product
earlier but you didn't even have to do
anything extra
after all you would have gone to walmart
to pick up your groceries whether or not
you ordered the mouse
another category that won't be going
online anytime soon is home improvement
items
if you're installing a cabinet and run
out of screws it makes a lot more sense
to simply make a quick trip to home
depot or lowe's instead of trying to
order screws from amazon
also when you go to the store in person
you can usually consult with home depot
employees who are generally quite
knowledgeable home depot literally hires
professional plumbers carpenters and
electricians to help customers find
products and give them tips on
installation this has become an
invaluable service for many customers
and if you don't believe me just take a
look at home depot stock while they have
cooled down recently their stock has
been going parabolic for years
and as physical retailers continue to
embrace such on-demand categories we'll
likely see consumers spend more money at
these retailers than ever
before on top of struggling with some
inherent shortfalls online retailers
have also been losing some of the key
advantages that made them better in the
first place like price about 10 years
ago a phenomenon called showrooming was
extremely common this is when consumers
go to a store to check out a product and
then go home to purchase a product
online because it's cheaper well this
made a lot of sense a decade ago and
it's not as applicable today given that
physical retailers have managed to close
the price gap
some retailers even offer special
in-store discounts which simply further
incentivizes in-store shopping and this
makes sense given that home delivery is
not cheap by any means
amazon had to run a money losing
operation for decades in order to
eventually achieve the economies of
skill required to make home delivery
profitable and with time amazon has only
increased the cost of their prime
subscription which now sits at 140
aside from charging consumers for
delivery amazon also charges sellers for
fulfillment as well amazon sellers
generally have to pay three to six
dollars for each item amazon fulfills
depending on its size
and as you would guess sellers are just
going to pass on this cost to consumers
now you can't really blame amazon for
these fees given that their net margin
is in the single digits however this
gives physical retailers the perfect
opportunity to be competitive in terms
of price and that's exactly what they've
done while mark has actually overtaken
amazon in terms of cheapness in several
categories including baby supplies
cleaning supplies medicine and personal
hygiene in other categories such as
makeup toys and pet food amazon has
maintained a lead meanwhile in some
other categories such as snack and food
prices walmart and amazon offer
identical prices to the penny
so clearly it's no longer a case of it's
always cheaper online
now it depends on product category and
in the long term you're not really going
to save money by choosing one or the
other in terms of product prices however
by shopping at physical retailers you
don't have to pay annual subscription
fee or delivery fees so it could
actually be cheaper to shop in person
and finally as for the last main factor
driving forward to physical retailers is
the shopping experience itself nowadays
people have gotten lazier than ever
before and have arguably gotten spoiled
with home delivery but even despite this
there's something special about
in-person shopping that you just can't
get with online shopping and i'm not
talking about weekly grocery shopping or
essential purchases rather i'm talking
about purchases that you've been saving
up for and are looking forward to take
the iphone for example eight years ago i
remember watching ijustine camping
outside of an apple store to be one of
the first people in the world to get an
iphone 6. with the rise of online
shopping apple has made it possible to
simply pre-order the iphone and get it
delivered to your house on the day it's
released but having the phone delivered
to your doorstep simply doesn't have the
same excitement and satisfaction as
buying it in store
now that's of course an extreme example
but this applies to smaller purchases as
well
buying shoes online isn't the same as
going to a nike store with your friends
and i believe most consumers feel the
same way given that the majority of
shoppers still prefer to shop in store
and here's the reasons they cite for
this preference 33 of respondents to the
survey suggest that they prefer to view
touch and interact with physical
products 26 percent of respondents
suggest that they enjoy the overall
shopping experience that a physical
location provides and 13 suggest that
they like the immediacy that in-store
shopping offers hearing this physical
retailers have placed a significant
emphasis on improving the in-store
experience from buffing up customer
support to making the entire process
seamless and it seems like these
improvements have been working and given
that consumers still prefer in-store
shopping in general
throughout this entire video we've
discussed the various advantages of
physical retailers and the bigger
shortfalls of online retailers and while
online retailers do have their
disadvantages i don't want to give off
the impression that online retailers are
doing poorly people are spending more
money than ever before online and this
will only increase moving forward but
with that being said i also don't think
that innovative retailers are going
anywhere either
in fact i think they'll perform
tremendously as well
the problem with physical retailers 10
years ago was that they were just simply
trying to replicate amazon they simply
threw together a website and started
shipping products to people's houses
this wasn't very successful given that
physical retailers weren't offering
anything unique or special in comparison
to amazon
but over the years the best retailers
have learned to leverage their physical
locations to offer something that amazon
can't this includes pickup and return
convenience immediate availability and a
unique shopping experience
and as long as physical retailers
continue to lean into the factories that
make them unique i don't think they'll
be going anywhere but that's just what i
think do you guys prefer online shopping
or in-store shopping comment that down
below also drop a like if you wish your
packages didn't get lost in the mail on
a regular basis
and of course consider checking out our
international channels to watch our
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing and see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one